ただいまー!!!
はじめしゃちょーです
というわけで、４日間東京にいました〜
でもね、結構、久しぶりに東京に行って
4 日間も東京にいたんですけど、
そんなになんか
久しぶりだったんで、あまり嫌な気持ちにはならず、
結構、楽しかったです！
東京 最高!!
とまでは言いません。
はい、で久しぶりに静岡に帰ってきたんですけども
すいません、やっぱり東京行くと
バタついちゃって
ちょっと動画が撮れなかったんですけども
今ちょっと僕のチャンネルを見ると
チャンネル登録者数が
590万人
になっておりました
ありがとうございます
やばいね もうすぐ、もうすぐついに
600万人になってしまう
というわけで、
600万人記念質問コーナーをしようと思います！
結構久しぶりですね
久しぶりに質問コーナーをやります
で、 この動画のコメント欄
この動画のコメント欄にコメントを書いてください
質問でもいいです
質問コーナーと言いつつ、質問コーナーじゃないんで
あの僕に言いたいこと！
やって欲しいこと！
文句！リクエスト！一言！
なんでもいいので、あの〜なんか〜こう
言っ てください。それを
質問コーナーの動画に使わせていただきます
あの、面白いのも使うかもしれないし、
しょうもないのも使うかもしれないし、
真面目な質問も使うかもしれないし、
誹謗中傷は......
やめていただきたいところではあります
まあ、なんでもいいです
もう好きなことを書いていただくと、
なんか僕が、こう
お⁉︎って思ったやつだったら
どんどん採用しようと思いますので
えー、みなさんぜひこのコメントに書いて
ください 。で、
えー、締め切りなんですけども
ちょっと読めないんすよね。今回、
今回締め切りが読めないんですよ
一応、イメージとしては
600万人いった
タイミング で出そうと思います
質問コーナー。なんで、
あの〜いつ公開かわかんないんで、
ちょっと締め切りもいつかなんとなくわかんないんで
あの〜すいません
ちょっと今回アバウトなんですけども、だいたい、
あーなんか６００万人行きそうだな
まあ、どれくらいかかるか分からないんですけどね
こっから伸びないという可能性もありますから
そ し たら、もう
僕は一生、
永遠に質問コーナーが出来なくなってしまいます
600万人に行くのが早ければ早いほど
質問コーナーが早くなりますので、
皆さん、是非、チャンネル登録の方も
よろしくお願いします
なんか、そこらへんにポチッと
押せばできると思うんで
じゃあ、コメントタイム!!!
今、コメントを書いてください！
うううぁあああ~
うっぁあああああ！
やー、やっぱ東京行くと、疲れるっすわ〜
まあ、色んな案件も含めて、
動画たくさん撮ってきたんで、
まあ、いろいろね
公開できればいいなって思っております
お楽しみに！
はい、みなさん
コメント、書けましたでしょうか
チャンネル登録者数600万人に
達した日本人は今のところ、
聞いてないとお伺いしておりますので
まあ、いけたらいいっすね
もう数字がデカすぎてさ〜
もう訳わかないんすよね
600万って、もう
まあ、600万記念にふさわしい
面白い質問コーナーにしたいと
思っておりますので
みなさん、コメントの方、
そして、
チャンネル登録よろしくお願い致します
そしてっ！！
その600万人記念の質問コーナーで
あの
重大発表というか、
ちょっと、とんでもねぇ
お知らせをしようかなと
思っております
おっとっとっと
これ以上言うと
ハードルが上がっちまう
重大かどうか分かんないすけど
結構、えっ!?
みたいな
え〜、きっと
お知らせが
お知らせを
する予定なので、是非！
お楽しみにっ！
いや〜、もうなんか
ちょっと体張りすぎて
ここがすごい筋肉痛です、今
というわけで、みなさん
コメントお待ちしておりますっ！
じゃあなっ！
やぁ、ゆるいな、今日
まあ、いいや